welcome to this video playing endless
fighter from India Indian flag no name
he know what sir he also had to
Bangladesh like at some point ok let's
see kind of would be no need structure
come on what about b5 is this possible
yeah maybe let's let's play that if I
have the possibility I probably should
should take it okay if I've se5 a threat
it's possible if I have takes d6 mm-hmm
maybe ok yeah probably just take it or
should I am a banker gambit style and
plain banco gambit star-like just just
letting him take and play a six maybe
it's possible but still i rather take a
pawn that second yeah okay he can he get
the Knight to c4 but it's not so
dramatic i can always go bishop a six
and exchange that he has one problem
this is the right only two it's really
not a good a good piece ok the question
is now hmm yeah no I don't want to take
really at the moment at the moment he
cannot move the night se2 hangs and
maybe Knight b6 as Sam isn't it as an
interesting threat now not sure what
he's doing against that
mmm he's doing nothing against it okay
it's not it's not a big threat per se
but I thought this would help me okay no
I can I can take if I want but not sure
if it's a good move if I go Bishop to d3
attacking the pawn maybe he's he needs
to play and I think he needs to play a 3
here cannot move the night and he for
hang so I think he needs to play a three
there is no good to discovery and have
three year I thought Queen a six maybe
okay let's just get rid of the bishop he
at one point he plays Knight therefore
anyway and I need to retreat i'll give
it up my plan is to go 97 here and now
nitey 5d3 if possible or maybe c5
likessee 49 to 53 and for the moment of
course be to Hanks so yeah this is a
question take it or not taking it as not
bad in terms of the light squares but
not so great for my king yeah but he
does not really have have a clear way to
my king so let's let's just take it
I intend to go to to see form on e6 a
player 5 and I don't want to spend too
much time here yeah and five typical way
to answer ecigs yes is trying to take
him how to how to improve my position
i'd like i'd love to get the rook to a3
really something like that I wonder I
wonder about a queen here maybe and
might I could move the night I mean I
don't necessarily need to allow him to
take it but but where to go yeah I don't
really see where to go with the night
yeah I'm not sure about queen bee
sunlight looks a bit strange maybe I'm
rupee one awesome hmm but I want to I
won't really want to have look III
coming
at least I'm attacking d5 p.m. so okay
jump I'm not sure if the capture at the
front okay but this was my plan anyway
and then Queen a six
maybe Queen a eight in some positions to
keep the five attacked it's 92 move 92 e
for he might seek the exchange ok I
don't I don't have time to think this
through even more
okay i want to pawn at least
not sure what he's thinking about really
doesn't he need to take of course here
and he's going he's got look it's mm-hmm
yeah this is singing yeah I probably
need to do that
no I cannot do that came
this is designed to attack in six from
the side check
check time morning check yeah I cannot
really do any comments any more little
time check check check check check check
check check mate whoa I made it and it
was very close time wise yeah very very
tough game tough game I don't think I
should I should win this really maybe
I'm too pessimistic now computer I just
play see 40 and wins okay this is really
a promotion uno taking yeah yeah this is
of course strong yeah the the C porn is
the shield against my seat bone and I'm
just doing everything with tempo here
yeah okay this I couldn't couldn't
calculate I took which is probably
probably drawing I don't I don't think I
can win this I mean in the in the game
just how we played it it wasn't draw
Jack this is probably a drawn with best
play probably the curious thing about
this position is that maybe I can really
get this in the comp gives us a total
total win so maybe I really win the pawn
yeah maybe this is mitosis a wind
probably so we needed to do it somewhat
differently I think it really should be
enough to draw here for for for a white
not this one probably this threatens
rock d8 so i must react to that rock dat
seven so this one yeah they can also be
taking it now as a mistake but he gets
this something like that okay i can go
here yeah I retain some chances I retain
some chances anyway yeah complicated
stuff thanks for watching